what's going on guys this is rob and as
those of you who follow me on Twitter
know yet we're driving yes we are quit
hassling me about driving and doing
vlogs but as those of you guys are
following on Twitter now my cpu fan
the bed yeah yesterday or the day before
something like that anyway this lil man
doesn't know how to draw it man learn to
drive man but um anyway as those of you
guys who follow me now my cpu pay-tv you
fan yeah completely just went kaput so
it makes sense it was a stock fan i had
a fly k year and a half two years or
something like that it was only a matter
of time before just totally went kaput
so i ordered new one good news is
currently sunday newegg has shifted i
had a rush delivered and had at rush
processed so basically they're like
overnight next day air what is the next
business day here whatever it is where
you get like overnight it to you because
I got to tell you guys it's killing me
not making videos I'm dying to do some
more Infinity Gauntlet videos it's
driving me crazy so here's what I want
to do the fan supposed to get in
tomorrow supposed to get in on monday
and i'm going to try to see if i can
make a video and have a couple of them
done and ready to be uploaded by the
time comic con comes around that way i
can have videos scheduled and upload
through through YouTube as I'm gone for
comic-con now there's no promise of that
there's no guarantee it may not happen
I'm just letting you guys know that's
that's what I'm trying to do whether or
not it works it on I have no earthly
clue i really have no idea um we're to
stop by right now so i think i think
we're safe to to talk for a minute but
um but yeah so how's everything going
with you guys I haven't asked you guys
that how's everything going with you
guys how are you guys doing how are you
guys hanging in there I know some of you
guys are in school some of the guys have
family some of you guys are trying to
figure out what you want to do how are
you guys doing I feel like not enough
like commentators ask like how their
fanbase is doing so that's that's what i
want to ask i want to ask how you guys
are doing how you guys are holding up me
I'm holding up amazing
I'm holding up so well goddess
everything's taken off like I'm getting
all these new followers on Twitter which
is cool because people were like your
channels on marriage which is always
nice to hear but it's like the most
common theme like people follow me on
Twitter than 0 tweet out and i'll just
be like your channels awesome you're
much better than comic story and I'm
like yes I know Benny's not nearly as
good as I am because because it's just
true no me and Benny I know a lot of you
guys are send me messages on YouTube you
guys have been like are you and Vinny
fighting like you inventing hate each
other stuff like that here's here's the
deal guys any kind of that you know like
nitpicking at each other that we do on
like the podcast or anything it's all
friendly banter me and bidding have
nothing but the utmost respect for each
other so don't worry it's not it's all
good we're not the band's not breaking
up so so yeah it's I just feel so good
today I'm going over to the guys house
so I'm gonna watch some Sunday Night
Football I'm gonna watching people play
and get the hell beat out of them I'm
love you guys follow cause of all I'm
actually pulling up next a car so
somebody here in a minute it's going to
think that I'm like recording them to
put them on YouTube what are you doing
like some old man like were you doing
young whippersnapper why are you
recording me and put me on youtube on
the youtubes but I don't have any of the
guys follow college football at all but
last night the Kentucky and South
Carolina game my god what a game that's
that's hands down one of the best games
i've seen this play in a long time let
alone just college games that I've seen
played it was unbelievable it was just
damn back and forth back and forth
trading touchdowns the running game
seemed to blow through both defenses
which is weird because normally South
Carolina has like a solid defense and
people usually just like really can't go
through there i just can't penetrate
their defense there a defensive line
that well but whatever it was maybe they
were off their game maybe we were just
exceptional on ours I don't South
Carolina's done as good as they used to
be in years past right now they're like
3 and 2 overall
so they're not nearly as good as a as
they have been in years past but they're
still pretty damn good nonetheless so
I'm really ecstatic about about beating
North Carolina now whether or not this
holds up I don't know I think we're two
positions away from qualifications for
bowl games so I really really hope we
get into it but yeah I know earlier
today the Browns the Cleveland Browns
and the Tennessee Titans were playing
and last I saw it was 14 20 Titans were
beat the out of the grounds so
that's not uncommon because the browns
suck the Titan is only the greatest team
ever but the browns suck but yeah so I'm
doing good I am I am doing good I'm
doing good i had a really good
conversation with Raj the other day
where I was talking like an erection
yesterday before I went over the guys
place I was talking to him about you
know moving and about want to go to
Tennessee and you know told him about
the whole deal like Jessica and that
conversation because I don't you guys
who have been following me on Twitter on
a lot of guys know about the whole thing
with jess and and yet it's just one of
these things you know where I'm trying
to make sure that I move for the right
reasons and I've got everything here I
mean I've got friends here I've got
family here there's there's every reason
to stay here and he has to be a really
good question he said you know like like
why do you want to go to Tennessee that
or why do you want to go to Seattle
that's the question you got to ask
and also that's a damn good question
because honestly I really couldn't think
of anything if you get there that I
couldn't get here I mean it's a more
progressive City and it's more advanced
technologically and so on but you know I
mean unless I live downtown i'm not
going to be able to take advantage of
that fiber optic internet you know that
gigabit internet speeds so so i don't
know you know in the end i'll get it all
sorted out you know and i'll get it all
taken care of bata but it's no time to
dwell no time to dwell comic-con is
coming up america new york comic con is
coming up in like a week no not even
that in like three or four days i am so
excited i actually just found out
earlier today me Benny I think Dave are
all flying into the same airport north
carolina and all leaving on the same
flight so that worked out
awesome so me and Ben you're going to
get together and let's dave is on a
different flight me and Ben you're going
to get together and we're all going to
hang out and we're going to chill and
probably get like some b-roll footage
and I might just upload it directly to
YouTube but I know that like it's stupid
expensive to use the internet the
airport Wi-Fi which as I understand it
isn't even that great like the quality
isn't even that high so so I don't know
yeah just just want to touch base with
you guys just wanted to say what's this
video blogs like six and a half minutes
or something like that so I'm going to
end this but but yeah you know if you
guys are good keep on keepin on if you
guys aren't doing so good then then
hopefully you guys can get out of the
slump that you're in and and yeah so
America anyway I'll see you guys later
peace